ja in der Ukraine gehen auch am Putins
Geburtstag die gegen offensiven weiter
und sie gehen mit einer rabiatät weiter
und mit einer Geschwindigkeit weiter wie
man es kaum glauben kann wir sehen uns
Aufnahmen an von Hamm wies von
amerikanischen haben wie es die jetzt
von ukrainischen Soldaten gefahren
werden und das sieht aus wie ein
Actionfilm es sind haben wie sie mit
voller Geschwindigkeit hier durch den
Granaten Hagel der Russen sich bewegen
wir sehen jetzt gleich hier der fliegt
fast der ist jetzt in der Luft und jetzt
ist der nächste hier werden russische
Positionen ja gestürmt von diesen haben
wir es und das ist genau die ukrainische
Strategie im Süden des Landes in der
Region Carson dort mit aller
Geschwindigkeit so schnell wie möglich
den Gegner zu überrennen an ihm vorbei
zu rennen eben in die Flanke zu fallen
und dann eben ja die Position von hinten
einzunehmen wir sind jetzt hier
ukrainische Soldaten die dann die
Position erstürmen nachdem die haben wie
es außen rumgefahren sind und vielleicht
können wir sowas einmal ansehen weil
solche Aufnahmen sind tatsächlich
einzigartig hier dieser haben wie der
quasi fliegt der springt durch die Luft
und ein weiterer der auch springt und
ein an einem zerstörten russischen
Fahrzeug vorbei fährt
das hat zur Folge man mag es kaum
glauben dass die Ukrainer so schnell
vorrücken dass die Russen selbst ihre
Mittel und Langstreckenwaffen nicht
zurückziehen können und wir haben ja ein
weiteres Video und das ist ziemlich
einzigartig wird konzentrieren uns mal
auf diesen Bereich gleich besser zu
sehen dort brennt bereits etwas und die
explodiert gleich noch und was wir da
explodieren sehen ist ein sogenannter BM
27 uragan ein Raketenwerfer der Russen
ein großer Raketenwerfer
und der hat eine Reichweite von 35 km
und das ganz besonderes wir sehen uns
hier unten ist dass der nicht von
Artillerie oder von Raketen zerstört
wurde sondern von einem ukrainischen
Panzer das heißt der ukrainische Panzer
der natürlich für Nahkampf maximal ein
zwei Kilometer Entfernung gedacht ist
hat es jetzt hier geschafft sich an
diesen russischen Raketenwerfer heran zu
Kirschen wenn man so will und hat ihn so
überrascht wir sehen Sie noch einmal die
Russen kommen also nicht weg der
explodiert die Kamera geht nach unten
und wir sehen verantwortlich dafür war
tatsächlich dieser ukrainische Panzer
hier unten der auf ihn geschossen hat
das also immer noch Fotos wie es danach
aussieht hier dieser uragan wie gesagt
35 km Reichweite ungefähr 20 Raketen der
auf einmal abschießen kann eigentlich
eine mittelstreckenwaffe die weit hinter
der russischen Front liegen sollte aber
eben von den Ukrainern direkt erreicht
wurde schauen uns das ganze nochmal auf
der Karte an und sehen hier was im Süden
passiert ist nämlich das allein seit dem
Wochenende dieses Gebiet hier oben
befreit wurde und die Russen eben
ungefähr 30 bis 40 Kilometer
zurückgedrängt wurden die ukrainische
Offensive geht heute in die beiden
Richtung weiter das heißt man versucht
entlang diszineerco und hier oben vom
Brückenkopf am Fluss in hulette
vorzudringen das also die Situation in
der Ukraine doch auch in Russland tut
sich unfassbares wir haben zum ersten
Mal russische Soldaten die nicht in den
Krieg wollen die rebellieren die ihre
Waffen zeigen und sagen wir gehen nicht
in die Ukraine wir machen das nicht
diese Aufnahmen hier auch mit englischen
Untertiteln in dem Fall Soldaten die
sagen wir sind in Belgorod wir sind 500
Mann wir sind bewaffnet aber wir haben
seit einer Woche keine Unterkunft wir
haben kein Essen bekommen wir müssen
unser eigenes Geld ausgeben um Essen zu
kaufen und alles was wir uns gegeben hat
ist ein Gewehr und wir werden mit diesem
Gewehr alleine nicht in die Ukraine
gehen das machen wir nicht das also
erstmal ziemlich einzigartige Aufnahmen
allerdings wird es jetzt interessant die
vermummten hier vorne die wir sehen die
regelsführer das sind keine russischen
Soldaten sondern das sind man sieht es
eine Badges auf ihren auf ihrer Seite
das sind Söldner der Privatarmee Wagner
und das lässt einen internen Machtkampf
vermuten das also hier innerhalb des
russischen Militärs und innerhalb der
Söldner Armeen die immer stärker werden
unter dem sogenannten putinskochin dass
dort ein Aufstand tobt gegen die
russische Armee gegen die Armeeführung
und man kämpft sozusagen um die Gunst
Putins und man kämpft aber auch um die
Hoheit der Truppen eben hinter der Front
das also Soldaten die nicht an die Front
wollen nicht etwa weil sie gegen den
Krieg sind sondern weil sie von Wagner
Söldnern eben aufgewiegelt wurden und
dann so in dieser Art und Weise nicht
mehr gehen wollen parallel haben wir
eben dass diese dass diese Videos
verteilt werden auf diesen ganzen
telegram Kanälen von Wagner wir sind
hier noch mal ein Soldat der das hier in
die Kamera hält das sind die Patronen er
sagt nur die Patronen habe ich gekriegt
ich habe nicht mal ein Gewehr dazu
gekriegt das also unfassbare Aufnahmen
die aber nicht zufällig wie es aussieht
und nicht originär durch die Soldaten an
die Öffentlichkeit gelangen sondern weil
die Söldner der Wagner Armee von Herrn
prigorcin ein enger Freund von Putin das
eben wollen und damit die russische
Armeeführung angreifen
[Musik]